hey legal eagles law school is really
expensive so students are always asking
me if they should work during law school
to help defray the cost well today we're
gonna talk about the pros and cons of
working during law school and whether
it's right for you by the end of this
video you'll know whether you should
take a job while being a full-time law
student so stick around law school is an
investment it has a high upfront cost
tuition is often over fifty thousand
dollars per year plus living expenses
which add in another twenty to thirty
thousand dollars it's not uncommon for
students to graduate with over two
hundred thousand dollars in law school
debt alone so I understand the
inclination to work during law school to
help defray some of those costs the
question is should you work during law
school is it worth it in my opinion if
you are a full-time law student no you
should not work during law school
absolutely not
don't even think about it and there are
several reasons for this first law
school is like having two full-time jobs
already
you go to class from 10:00 to 3:00 and
then study from 3 to 9 and you work
weekends as well law school alone just
doing the studying and preparing for
class and going to class is basically
like two full-time jobs
back-to-back it doesn't seem like there
is additional time to factor in another
full-time job on top of that law school
entails a different kind of studying
than most people are used to and it will
take you longer to prepare for class
than you're accustomed to
you will read so much more than you did
in college and unlike college you can't
fake reading the assigned reading like
you did before your class is an
undergrad almost all first-year law
students face a very steep learning
curve you're going to have a vocabulary
of words that you've never heard before
or regular words that have a different
meaning in the legal context it's a
whole new set of rules it's like
learning piano guitar and chess all at
the same time concurrently in different
classes and that's why the ABA actually
puts a limit on how much you can work in
law school
the ABA says that you can work no more
than 20 hours per week for full-time law
students so they're there
the fact that you should be focusing on
law school and not other other monetary
opportunities another factor is stress
law school is already considered the
most stressful time in students lives
I've seen Marines have mental breakdowns
under the stress of law school so adding
another job on top of that is just a
recipe for disaster but most importantly
the thing about law school is that
grades matter the most important thing
that you can do to get the job that you
want in the legal field is to get good
grades grades are 90% of what it takes
to get the job that you want whether
it's a big firm job or a clerkship or
going into public interest everyone's
going to look at your grades and better
grades will open up more opportunities
and if you take on a job you will be
competing against students who are not
working and who are focusing on law
school a hundred percent and that's an
unfair competition one of the main
points of law school is to become a
lawyer yes but it's also to increase
your earning power by getting into the
state-run monopoly that is the attorneys
bar so part of the point of becoming a
lawyer is to earn more as an attorney so
let's say that you are somehow able to
make fifty thousand dollars per year
while in law school I don't think that's
very realistic while actually being in
law school but let's say you were able
to make fifty thousand dollars but at
the cost of slipping a few points in
your GPA well the difference between
graduating in the top 10% of your class
and the middle 50% or so could result in
a difference in salary when you graduate
a $50,000 less in year one and that
difference or deficit is only going to
compound year after year after year the
place where you start when you graduate
it largely determines where you end up
five ten and twenty years later so while
it might have made sense to earn $50,000
while in law school that could end up
costing you millions of dollars over the
course of your career and keep in mind
that your 1l year is by far the most
important year in law school your 1l
grades will define where you're able to
get a 1l summer job and those two things
will define where you're able to get
eight
well summer associate job and that's
largely where people get their
employment prospects when they graduate
from law school so if ever there was a
year not to have another job it would be
your 1l year when you get into your 2l
in 3l year you'll probably get your your
feet underneath you and you can decide
whether you want to take on the
additional risk of another job or
perhaps some extracurricular activities
but your first year grades will define
whether you're able to get a clerkship
or a summer internship or whether you're
possibly able to transfer to a better
school so don't shortchange your 1l
grades above everything else
in fact many schools prevent you from
doing extracurriculars during your first
year let alone a full-time job so the
bottom line is that getting another job
especially during your 1l year but
probably for the rest of law school it's
just not worth it don't go down that
road don't be Pennywise and
pound-foolish
understand law school for the investment
that it is you're probably going to be
taking on a large amount of loans and it
would be terrible to throw away that
investment just to get a few more
dollars during the school year which
will really impact your ability to get
good grades so in my view having a
full-time job in law school just isn't
worth it focus on your grades focus on
your final exams and do the best that
you can that will have the best result
in succeeding in law school and your
career as an attorney now if you're
preparing for law school and want even
more strategies and tactics that will
show you how to get A's in law school
download our free ultimate pre-law
checklist it's our free gift to you the
link to that is down below it will give
you a head start on your peers by the
time you get to law school and also
please click on the like and subscribe
buttons the more people that subscribe
the more videos we'll make on how to
crush law school so did you work during
law school did you regret it or did you
think it was a great idea let me know in
the comments I'd love to hear from you
and until next time at legal eagle think
like a lawyer and ace the exam hailey
legals
blah blah okay you will read so much
more than you did in college so let's
say that you were somehow able to make
$50,000 per year in law school